hi I'm Samir syak I am an ophthalmic
surgeon and a physicist and I'm
presenting about University Hall which
is a universal computational tool to
select the optimal intraocular lens for
patients on the growing cataract surgery
we have a product that's being used by
many people throughout the world and I'm
going to show specifically how
Mathematica was a core technology that
helped us get a very powerful and
flexible tool so come to talk
I thanks for coming to my talk I'm Samir
syak I'm an atomic surgeon and I'm also
a physicist and I'm going to talk I
spoke about similar things before but
I'm going to talk about the most common
blinding disease in the world which is
cataracts and how this can be reversed
and more specifically how it can be
reversed in a beautiful way where you
actually can see much better than you've
ever seen in your whole life hopefully
and then I'm going to discuss how we
developed a computational tool that
helps us do this specifically select an
intraocular lens for specific patient
for specific eye that will make the
vision basically perfect and of course
since we are here I'm going to discuss
how Mathematica has played a role in the
development of this tool okay so I will
try to go pretty fast through the
introductory part and we can stop me
anytime and then hopefully we still can
get dinner tonight
okay so credits
Steph and I Brandt was a major
contributor to the software development
and then a number of people from my
clinic and you may have heard about some
of the other guys such as this guy here
this is the abstract you've seen so the
plan on the talk and we talked about
vision blindness and the universality of
cataracts briefly I'm gonna show three
models of reversing the cataracts
blindness and I'm going to show three
things you really need to do to trend
towards the perfect vision and then I'm
gonna give three examples of how we use
Mathematica to achieve that so you may
recognize this this is a Picasso from
the blue period you can see it I think
it's in DC this is the summary of your
lives so basically you're born here you
die roughly here and these are the eye
conditions that you will develop for
people develop they are fairly common I
have some percentages here it does
depend if you live long enough you'll
develop presbyopia you don't need to be
very old to have nearsightedness or
farsightedness if you live a little bit
longer you will definitely develop a
cataract and if you live a little bit
longer than you're definitely going to
go blind from your cataract so that's
why 90 well 90% anywhere between say 75
to 90% of the blinds in the world is due
to cataract and so that's an important
kind of little map all right and now
nearsightedness is also a problem and
it's related to my talk you see why a
little bit later but this shows you in a
particular geography in Taiwan is this
place not only the fact that
nearsightedness by the time you are 18
grows to the point of being nearly 80%
but through the years it has gotten
worse and worse right so there are a lot
of people who are saying your sighted
independent of having a cataract because
a cataract you get much later in your
life astigmatism is a big problem this
is a very nice slide that I'm not going
to discuss for the sake of time but one
point to understand is that a stigmatism
is really the worst of all if you're
nearsighted
you can see near if you're if you're
farsighted and young you can you can see
far right if you have astigmatism we
cannot see anything cannot see near you
cannot see far everything is distorted
right so getting rid of astigmatism is
is going to be very important and if you
can do it and we it's only very recently
that we've been able to address this in
in a specific surgical way in particular
at the time of cataract surgery so it's
a fairly recent development just to give
you an example I'm going to be talking
sometimes in terms of diopters the D
here's four diopter so if you have one
day after of myopia this is how you see
2/3 you can see it goes blurry pretty
quick so if you miss your computation by
one diopter you're basically shifting
your patient from seeing this crisp to
seeing this if you miss it by 3 diopter
then you you're shifting your patient
from seeing this crest to that so that's
the importance of having really a good
computation just for the a referenced
article reference the first time the
cataract surgery was done with an
implant that that was put in the eye
that's roughly 50 years ago maybe 60 so
the the error on the computation was of
20 diopters okay just so that to give
you a historical you know perspective we
can do better than that and and but it's
it's not perfect and and we are in the
game of making it much better much
closer you know to the what's on the
left side so here are some actual
cataracts I do operate cataracts of this
severity even in this country some
operating this coming Monday I'm going
to be operating a bunch of them maybe 20
or 25 but two or three would be this bad
okay generally speaking in the Western
world they are not usually this bad but
once they are this bad you really don't
see anything it's not gonna be like this
I mean if you have this cataract you're
not gonna see that you're not gonna see
anything all right so there are three
real-world cataract environments and
I've worked in pretty much all three and
I have collaborators and users of my
system my software in all environments
one is a relatively early cataracts in
the twenty forty range that's the vision
2040s where twice as as bad as normal
with access to very high-tech tools an
example is the United States Illinois or
San Diego okay then you have Hardware
cataracts in a twenty one hundred range
with good access to technology maybe not
as much as what we have here examples of
Poland and Greece just these are
specific places where I do have
collaborators and and then very hard
cataract which is H M means hand motion
they can only see the hand move or light
perception which is they can only see
the light right they cannot see numbers
they're gonna see letters I cannot see
your fingers they cannot see your hand
moves just just if they've is there a
light or is there not and this is from a
cataract and this is typically
represented by Eastern Mexico this you
know certain places like the state of
Oaxaca we've operated and I do have
collaborators there okay so what what do
you want to do so what you really want
to the first thing I want to do is to
remove the cataract and have we done
this before yes we've done it probably
four hundreds probably thousands of
years and there's been some techniques
not as elegant as what we have today but
people did this and that was all they
did now if you just remove the cataract
we have a lot of optical power in this
lens and if you remove it it's gone so
now you're creating a very bad problem
of farsightedness and sometimes the
patient can't
much more than they did before right so
ideally you want to correct that
so the second step is that you want to
correct the two myopia that existed or
the hyperopia by implanting in
intraocular lens okay the third thing
you want to do is to correct the
astigmatism
so the myopia and hyperopia as I was
telling you it's about half a century
that we we've been able to do this a
little more and to do it well maybe a
quarter of a century okay so for half a
century we had something to implant to
compensate for this power and to do it
well maybe about a quarter century
correcting astigmatism is more like an
eighth of a century maybe a dozen years
or so that we can have some device to
correct for that and then presbyopia
inability to see near as you age and
that's in one eighth of century we don't
have anything that's good enough at this
point but we won't worry about this we
would probably concentrate on the three
so this is an interactive lens it's
actually very very small this one in
particular does correct for stigmatised
we can see those dots here so stigmatism
has direction right so one direction is
steeper focus is liked more than the
perpendicular direction all right so
when you're correct you can just put it
spherical lens because then you miss
astigmatism so we want to put a lens
that itself has an asymmetry and this
asymmetry is marked by this little axis
here these are very very modern lenses
we didn't have good lenses like this
fifty years ago or 20 years ago we're
just starting to see them as I said in
the past maybe five to ten years
depending on how you want to count on
the quality and whatnot
to calculate this it does take a lot of
work and each manufacturer has their own
little website and whatnot this is a
representation of a stigmatism
this is steep this is flat you do a
computation here then you go to the
company and they tell you you enter the
data and whatnot and then they tell you
which you want to choose the size are
very annoying each each company has
their own site their own methods and
whatnot so here's an example this is one
company come other company a third
company so if I'm trying to find the
optimal lens it's like you're trying to
buy a ticket you know to fly to New York
so you go to American Airlines and you
look and you find maybe particular say
well maybe your night it has go ahead
okay so most of what I'm going to talk
about is for humans okay and we'll talk
about robots later maybe at the end of
time okay thank you so so you buying
your ticket you go to American then you
say well maybe United has some things we
go to United sites and we start looking
for United say okay how about Southwest
and then you go to Southwest and are you
doing the comparison yourself by hand
and there are you know dozens of
airlines and then you it's not very very
useful and the companies are not gonna
be so nice as to provide you with others
so there are many others and this is
just a list of the the company that
manufactures intercalates so what we
wanted to do is to put everything
together right to have a system that
includes a spherical computations
meaning for what sphere do you need okay
and for all intraocular lens
manufacturers Ohio L means intraocular
lens with multiple formulas for
optimization to include corrected
correct toric computation because there
was a lot of confusion even amongst the
companies how to do the toric
computation toric means the a stigmatic
part people didn't know how to do it and
they were doing using algorithms were
inaccurate a number of times these are
some of the collaborators again and I'm
going to give some examples of what we
we did so here's the basic architecture
of our system so we have a core
calculator here that has all the
computation for the intraocular lenses
we have a huge length database it's
essentially Universal so I go everywhere
I talk to everybody I have people in my
clinic that connect to the different you
know come every time there is in your
lens and your intraocular lens that
appears we know about it we know its
characteristics we know its measurements
we know its power we know everything
about and we add it to our database okay
so that's that's our so that's a
universal database the calculator that
different methodologies calculating so
we have included
to the best of our knowledge a lot of
these either sound and accurate and then
we have the front end which is universal
which basically is a web interface we
have other ways of accessing that so
this is just an example of what you need
to do so you enter that data about the
surgeon and the patient and what not and
then measurement of the I what is the
length of the eye
what is the curvature of the cornea what
is the what is the desired outcome
because the desired outcome is not
necessarily always zero it could be a
little negative so that the patient can
can see a little bit more at near the
computer and so and so forth so you
enter a number of parameters and then it
gives you the best selection I don't
have it's like responding to this but if
you click on select lens here it will
give you a ranking of all of the lenses
that you selected the brands and the
models for right so you may say oh I
love Johnson & Johnson they're my best
friend so I'm gonna include them in the
search I love alcohol
I don't like Bausch and Lomb I'm not
going to include them inside so you can
pre-select and this pre selection is
here and then from the lenses that you
selected so you say I don't like to fly
United I don't like to fly Southwest
they mess up my they lose my luggage or
whatever so I don't include them it's
only the ones that you included that you
would get there so you have this this
kind of situation alright so now okay so
it works extremely well I can give you
access and we can see it run but now
since I am here it's mathematica time
I give three examples of how Mathematica
was useful to develop this now the
summary is that the summary is that we
developed a lot of things in Mathematica
but the other final implementation
that's running on on the server is
written in C++ and the reason is because
we were developing this when Wolfram was
attempting with very variable levels of
success to have a fully accessible fully
functional Wolfram language Mathematica
implementation on the web and but but a
lot of the core ideas are are developed
early Mathematica and then and then
field so one of them is a residual error
computation and basically what it is
yeah so very broadly all of these can be
thought of the ability to solve inverse
problems symbolically to allow solutions
that would be impossible or impractical
if performed only in America okay so if
you were doing numerically it would be
prohibitive but if you solve
symbolically first and then run the
solution numerically they it works nice
so here's an example if you want to know
for a given intraocular lens that you
put in what would the residual error be
okay will be minus 20 would be my 3 or 1
so there is a nonlinear equation that
you need to solve and if you solve it
every time you wouldn't be able to solve
it for every single manufacturer every
single intraocular lens it takes a lot
of time here's an illustration and this
was shown by Stefan and in a talk we
gave together so if you run it directly
here it's actually a thousand runs but
you get you have a half a second you
takes half a second if you solve it in
Mathematica first and then just run the
solution it does it in about the
hundredths of a second all right so you
gain so if you're going to try to be
universal and calculate all of these
lenses okay you have a tremendous
advantage here and you wouldn't be able
to do it otherwise okay now another
example is a stigmatism correction and
if you look here this is stigmatism at
the lens plane and this is at the
corneal plane if you look at the ratio
this ratio is always 1.5 okay so this is
incorrect and this kind of belief has
been maintained by many companies for a
long time maybe decades or more so we
did work that showed that in fact that
ratio varies depending on say the power
of the cornea and essentially the
lengths of the eye and it can be 1.5 for
average eyes but it can be as high as
two and it can be as low as 1 point 2
and if you don't take this into account
you get lots of errors so what we did
with this very simple math but you can
do it in Mathematica there's a slightly
more complex version of this but I'm
showing a simple version so you
basically extract what's called a Teresa
2 ratio which is a ratio between a
stigmatism value at the lens plane to
the stigmatism value at the corneal
plane okay and then you can compute it
and in terms of things that you can
measure in the calculator so we can go
into a specific calculator of alcohol of
Johnson & Johnson of Bashan nominal and
and see how they are doing it if they're
doing it correctly or not simply by
using this little formula here and this
was developed with the Loren kabra whose
work who works for me
all right the other I'll give you one
last example and then open to questions
and dinner so the last example again
this is the same IRL playing crappin but
what I'm trying to point here is that
this toric AOL's
intraocular lenses are discrete all
right
so at the cornea plane even you go from
one to one-and-a-half to two to
two-and-a-half etc well what if the
patient has a value of the stigmatism
that's in between you won't be able to
correct with that well there's another
technique which is called relaxing
incisions okay you put relaxing little
incisions in the cornea or outside the
cornea depending on what tool you're
using if it's a laser or or a diamond
knife or whatever and you can get also
correction but your corrections are also
discrete so I 1/2 3/4 1 and 1/2 3 so if
you have a patient who come with 1.9
with stigmatism okay then one way or
another they'll be left with about half
a diopter of astigmatism and that's
significant right it's not I'm not gonna
die but it's it's not going to be
perfect and if other errors are also
entering they may end up with more than
that so how can you get this to zero
that's a question so this is something I
did in Mathematica and basically the
idea here is the the solid circles
represent what you can correct with with
incisions and the dotted circle
correspond to what you can correct with
intraocular lens or the other way around
it doesn't matter right and the
intersection are points where if you
combine them then you can get perfection
zero stigmatism
so nobody's doing this right now but
here's the example for the 1.9 patient
actually for several patients for here's
the 1.9 patients so if you put your
toric lens in this direction and you put
your incision in this direction then you
will get zero astigmatism correction and
here's a representation of the surgery
itself so that's the eye of the patient
that's the cornea and what you would
need to do this is the axis of the Steep
where you have maximum maximum curvature
this is your cataract incision so you're
gonna be entering the eye from here
right and so these are going to be the
incision gonna make with the laser or
with the diamond knife it doesn't matter
if you diamond knife you'd put them a
little bit behind with the laser you put
them here and then you actually
interrupt your lens you would put in
here and then with combining this two
you get exactly zero so you eliminate
all of that stigmatism else combination
now the methodology for this was
developed
a lot of the computations were done in
Mathematica for the formal development
so anyway so here's my conclusion we
have three main cataract environments 20
40 20 110 motion the biometric tools may
be different secondary to combination of
the nature of the cataracts and the
socio economics of the region in most
environments you can still get excellent
measurements and thus excellent results
the universe IOL calculator is a
powerful tool used in all environments
with extra excellent outcomes so all of
these environments I discussed we do
have very very nice outcomes much
improved compared to what they had
before even in San Diego which is a very
fancy place you know the results are
validated into these three environments
and then we have an extension of that
and I'm not going to talk about here and
mathematic has been an effective tool at
different junctures of developing this
tool this Universal and full online
implementation Mathematica is under
consideration currently so thank you
very much you can contact me and I'll
take a few questions now and then we'll
go to dinner thank you
[Applause]